We have found the Higgs Boson.
So then the next question is,
what's next?
Well,
the large Hadron Collider,
this machine that is 20,
uh,
27 miles in circumference costing $10
billion is big enough to create the next
generation of particles.
So the Higgs Boson in some sense is the
last Hurrah for the old physics,
the old physics or what is called the
standard model,
which gives us quarks and electrons.
The new theory is going to take us into
dark matter.
Now we know dark matter exists.
Dark matter is invisible.
So if I held it in my hand,
you wouldn't see it.
In fact,
it would go right through my fingers,
go right through the Rock,
underneath my feet and go all the way to
China.
It would be reversed direction and come
back from China all the way here to New
York City and go back and forth.
So dark matter has gravitational
attraction,
but it is invisible and we are clueless
as to what dark matter really is.
The leading candidate for dark matter
today,
it's called the sparkle.
This particle is the next octave of the
string.
Now look around you.
Everything around you we think is
nothing but the lowest vibration of a
vibrating string.
The lowest octave in some sense.
But a string of course has higher
octaves,
higher notes.
We think that dark matter could in fact
be nothing but a higher vibration of the
string.
So we think that 23% of the universe,
which is,
which is the dark matter,
is contribution to the universe,
comes from a higher octave of the
string.
Now the standard model which we have
ample verification of only represents 4%
of the universe.
So the universe of atoms,
protons,
neutrons,
neutrinos.
That universe only represents 4% of what
there is.
23% is dark matter,
which we think is the next vibration up
of the string.
And then 73% of the universe is dark
energy.
Dark energy is the energy of nothing is
they energy at the vacuum between two
objects.
In outer space,
there's nothing,
nothing except dark energy,
dark energy,
which is pushing the galaxies apart.
So when people say if the universe is
expanding,
they say two things.
What's pushing the galaxies apart?
And what is the universe expanding into?
Well,
what's pushing the galaxies apart is
dark energy,
the energy of nothing.
Even vacuum has energy pushing the
galaxies apart.
And then what is the universe expanding
into?
Well,
if the universe is a sphere of some sort
and we live on the skin of the sphere
and the sphere is expanding,
what is a sphere expanding into?
Well,
obviously a bubble of balloon expands
into the third dimension,
even though the people living on the
balloon or two dimensional.
So when our universe expands,
what does that expand into?
Hyperspace a dimension beyond what you
can see and touch.
In fact,
string theory predicts that there are 11
dimensions of hyperspace,
so we're nothing but a soap bubble
floating in a bubble bath.
I was soap bubbles and so in some sense
the multiverse can be likened to a
bubble bath.
Our Universe is nothing but one bubble,
but there are other bubbles.
When two bubbles collide,
that could merge into a bigger bubble,
which could be the big bang.
In fact,
that's what probably the big bang is or
perhaps a bubble vision than half and
split off into two bubbles.
That could be the big bang or perhaps
the universe popped into existence,
out of nothing.
That is also a possibility,
and so the universe could essentially be
nothingness which was unstable and
created a soap bubble.
Now you may say to yourself,
well,
that can't be right because that
violates the conservation of matter and
energy.
How can you create a universe from
nothing?
Well,
if you can't calculate the total matter
of the universe,
it is positive.
If you calculated the total energy of
the universe,
it is negative because of gravity.
Gravity has negative energy.
When you add the two together,
what do you get?
Zero.
So it takes no energy to create a
universe.
Universities are for free.
A Universe is a free lunch and then you
had assault.
Well,
that can't be right because positive and
negative charges don't cancel out.
Therefore,
how can the university made out of
nothing?
Well,
if you calculate the total amount of
positive charge in the universe and
khaki,
the total amount of negative charge in
the universe,
and you add it up,
what do you get?
Zero.
The universe has zero charge.
Well,
what about spin galaxies spin,
right?
But they spin in all directions.
If you add up all the spins of the
galaxies,
what do you get?
Zero.
So in other words,
the universe has zero spin,
zero charge,
and zero matter energy content.
In other words,
the universe is for free.
Okay.